apparently if you rub banana skin on your face
it gives you a natural Botox effect
wait wait
let me finish my banana
banana from Peru
now in the in the element of this experiment
I'm actually only gonna do half of my face cause I wanna see
is that hair gel
anyway I'm only gonna do half of my face just to see
what this sort of before and after is
you rub it on and you leave it for 10 minutes and then you wash your face
and so we're gonna see what happens
I'll see you in 10 minutes
I mean it might be bogus but hey
it's like it's free because this is a by product
the banana wasn't free
and at least I didn't like the broccoli trend where you can't reuse
you have to eat the innards to get to the skin
and if you don't and if you throw the banana away just to get to the skin then
sorry no
don't be that person
tell you what
it feels really nice
I mean it's quite glowy
alright I'll see you in town actually this time
alright so my skin feels quite tight and like at you
you need to do it to feel it
but like there's like banana skin on my neck and it feels like tight
alright I'm gonna wash it off
so my skin is very soft
my pores are a little bit smaller on the side than the other side
and I definitely feel a little bit more snatched
so yes I would try that again
go rub a banana peel on your face today
unless you're allergic